check
all right we don't have to start now we
can invent it for a few
minutes we were talking about you
talking about the right hegelian reading
matt
i remember was remembering like the last
two weeks i think it was like two weeks
ago since marion was there
uh we brought up like the foucaulian
reading of hegel is kind of
fairly standard right always the
totalizing philosopher
rates the state that kind of stuff right
the servant of bureaucrats
yeah it's too bad your like later
interpreters can reflect badly on you
i i looked into that the the right left
hegelian thing though and it looks like
the
it used to be young hegelian and old
hegelian that was actually like an
opposition
i don't know i was reading around and
the young hegelians are the ones who
kind of do the uh
the the more secular interpretation and
then the old hegelians are the ones who
did the uh
the what we would say the right wing
hegelian interpretation and hegel's body
wasn't even cold when that division
popped up yeah yeah that's true
there's this real emphasis on creativity
and novelty
even more than fidelity to standard text
in like
french academia and the social sciences
right by the time foucault and dara that
were writing
hegel was considered pretty ubiquitous
right because of hibaleta and koyev and
even yosartra to a certain extent right
so he's one of the big h's
yeah exactly yeah i like kind of girl
so like the kind of implication he gave
was that oh
cyril isn't it oh yeah yeah not hume and
so like a lot of these uh
60 eaters was the kind of term he used
for them right maybe their name by
pushing against hegel and characterizing
him as responsible for everything that
was bad
precisely because they needed to be
original which meant you know
pushing against you know the big wigs
were all hegelians at that point
you know what i mean and then deleuze
broke the mold by writing on
hume and loving spinoza there you go
comparison
yeah all right well why don't we kick
this off sounds good yes let's kick it
[Music]
up
hello listeners and welcome to the pill
pod the podcast where
everything comes from nothing and the
points don't matter
i am your host plastic pills and with us
we have players
matt eric and guest i'm going to wait to
introduce
guest just to extend the suspense a
little bit
he's come for our reckoning and all of
us are quivering
as a result so our last public episode i
proposed
a vision of hegelianism as
something like walmart it's big it moves
into all the small neighborhoods
puts all the little shops out of
business and even though nobody really
likes it we have to keep going back
there all the time wow way to throw down
the gauntlet
because there aren't any other there
aren't any other options unless you're
deliz i wasn't even ready for that
hegelianism
is philosophy walmart but
we also have to be dialectical about it
because we always have to go back there
so which means today we have brought a
guest
whose very name invokes terror into the
hegel haters
all the way from london the real london
not london ontario
it is borna hello hi pleasure to
be here now born as a scary type of
person
you've got to understand because he
reads details and then remembers them
and he also reads charitably you know to
discover truths and not just to get a
hot take so
he's a very dangerous individual in this
day and age
not hopefully not that dangerous not the
usual pill pod fair
um so today we're continuing our talk of
the state and
of course the one thing that more or
less unifies what we've
been referring to as critical theory is
that the state
is bad and current events uh don't
really too
too much to dissuade that more or less
looks like a dumpster fire currently
as soon as it's faced with the crisis
and maybe today or soon in the future
i'm hoping we can move a little bit into
marx's
state i know that's another area of
borna's expertise
because marx wasn't particularly
fanatical about the state and he didn't
or he thought it would become irrelevant
long before now presumably but for today
uh we of course have states with us
hegel talked about it often
and we kind of see states as managerial
bureaucracies and so on sometimes they
discipline and punish
if you were listening to our last
episode and many of the critiques of the
state lead into critiques of
hegel and today we have borna here who
is a hegelian
but not the kind of hegelian it seems
that foucault and de las
et cetera uh are trying to refute or
trying to challenge
i want i don't wonder if anyone knows
the historical background to this
because
he tara hegel talks very favorably of
napoleon so maybe we can begin by
historicizing
a little bit if anybody knows
yeah i mean the apocryphal story and i
imagine borna can tell us whether or not
this is true
uh is that the battle of jenna friedland
which basically gave napoleon control
over germany
and brought the french revolution to the
backwards german-speaking world in a
sense
uh took place right as he was kind of
finishing the phenomenology of spirit
uh and the kind of pale hegel says is
that he saw him the emperor
you know world spirit himself in an
individual you know
march into the city crashing down the
old world and bringing with him the new
and that seemed to be the kind of
backdrop for hegel's like earlier
revolutionary period
the kind of standard tale that i've
heard is that you didn't necessarily
become more critical of napoleon
in the future but obviously by 1815
napoleon was over and done with
uh and the kind of argument we aid was
that
napoleon and thus the french revolution
had kind of fulfilled its historical
mission uh at least thus far uh and
therefore world history now decided to
discard them
uh and send napoleon packing to saint
helena and the french revolution kind of
got recontained
by the pushback by the various
reactionary states at least for a little
while
um yeah that's that's broadly right um
you know hegel does make a reference to
napoleon uh
in in in one of his letters to his
friend in around 1807 i believe
he says that he saw napoleon ride into
yana
which is where he was teaching at the
time and he calls napoleon world spirit
so he says something like you know i saw
a world spirit on a horse
riding into writing into jenna now
whether or not he actually saw napoleon
the man ride the horse in yena in terms
of
it actually happening is hard to say
but it is true that there was a battle
happening at the time that napoleon's
troops were
in this city um so he was probably maybe
speaking a little bit
um he was exaggerating let me just put
it that way
but it's a significant um historical
point because
it speaks to how hegel thought about um
political development and the role
of um political freedom in the world
especially how it relates to history
and i think if we're going to talk about
hegel and the state and what hegel
thought about
the political state one way we can
approach the topic is to think about
the role history and historical change
has in how states are configured
throughout different periods of human
history i should also say that like
hegel
was a master storyteller i mean in some
ways he calls the kind of
biggest story that everyone has been
told in the history of western
philosophy at the very least
and i imagine he knew that saying you
know well you know napoleon kind of was
near the city that i was at
just doesn't have the same kind of
resonance as saying you know i saw the
emperor there
wander in on his horse bringing you know
the new world with him right it's got a
bit more of a kind of poetic flourish to
it
uh speaking about it he's actually
present right
his metaphors are as big as his thoughts
there you go yeah
i'd like to interject even before we get
going because here's the big risk
is that we are going to alienate people
who have not read
hegel or born is going to alienate us
but the thing about eggel is
all of these terms that get thrown
around it's almost impossible to turn
them into
language that is comprehensible but i
our project is
sort of to create a safe space from
philosophy jargon
as much as possible which will make this
conversation in particular
a little difficult but jargon
is endemic in academic
chatter and the effect of that i think
is that it's
also convinced a lot of smart people
that they're not smart
so um if you're going to use terms
please try to put it
into as basic and english form or
furnish it with an example if you can
um as far as possible if we can
to try to unjargonize this and show its
relevance
that goes for any comment sections
associated with this
episode and i should say
um just in case anybody who's listening
has tried to read hegel
and felt that they were yeah it was an
insult to their intelligence and was
like wow you know i can't go through
this i must not be as smart as i thought
it was
i remember when i read richard russell's
pretty bad i should say history of
western philosophy
he was complaining about how hegel was
impossible to understand
and bertrand russell might not have been
a great interpreter of philosophy but
you know as the author of the principia
mathematica i don't think anyone would
deny that he was
a very smart man right so even you know
super intelligent people struggle with
trying to make sense of what the hell
hegel is saying and so
if you've ever read his book and you
kind of are wondering what's going on
don't feel bad you're in good company
well not to derail this
effusion of intellectual humility but
i think a good thing that i would like
to focus on
is the point that borna brought up at
first
is this idea that we are historical
beings
and just as good
historians of ideas we have to sort of
trace do we trace this idea
back to hegel this idea that we're
historical
it's like today we take this for granted
right we
we're on this sort of decade treadmill
right everything's
70s everything's 80s everything 90s
today
we're hyper aware that
we are historically determined to some
degree that
what is popular tomorrow isn't what's
popular yesterday
but for hegel's philosophy this was
something of like a revolutionary idea
right like the idea that thinking before
him
is static or a historical
i mean maybe that's something we could
sort of address because that's going to
be one of the most important things that
comes
out of it to marx as well when we talk
about him later
i remember when i was reading uh the
lectures on
you know philosophy of history and this
was quite a few years ago
but i remember hegel kind of
acknowledges the fact that there have
been historians uh going back at the
very least to herodotus and thucydides
uh who had interesting things to say
about the role history plays
in framing our conception of ourselves
right uh what he kind of implies
in the lectures is that yeah but there
hasn't been a philosophy of history
uh in the firm sense uh until modernity
right uh and he mentions a few different
predecessors people like herrera and so
on
but he says you know my thought you know
uh history has finally become
philosophical but
i do think if we're talking about
hegel's novelty he does have a lot of
claim to be an innovator in that respect
right making
history into a central philosophical
concern rather than a separate
discipline
that philosophers will occasionally
dabble into right well yes
this is true um i mean i you know
it is true that there were predecessors
even at
even in germany at the time or i should
say prussia at the time before hegel who
were doing
philosophies of history but however
hegel
can be said to take that project to its
completion
because of course not only does he have
a philosophy of history
meaning he he interprets human history
in a certain respect
but he reads philosophy itself
historically
right so he you know he famously gave
lectures about the ancient greeks
and the um medieval thinkers and then
the moderns and then the
german idealists you would lecture from
parmenides
and the last lecture would be his own
system
so i'm just pointing this out because
it's important for us to remember
or kind of to acknowledge that hegel
didn't simply have a
philosophy of history historical
thinking
and historicizing if we can use this
word which just means
treating concepts and ideas and people
as products and
as being products of and situated in
historical contexts
so hegel really takes that theme and
basically applies it to his entire
philosophy
if you're in a history of philosophy
class this is almost commonplace now
because when we teach history of
philosophy
i think all of us have probably taught a
course similar to that
or western thought or something like
that and you always historicize
now and is that something that would be
different from the way philosophy was
taught before
hegel i should just say to add to that
there definitely is a dialectical
quality to how those classes are taught
right like
well this is how kent contributed
hegel's thought and this is how hegel's
thought contributed to marx's thought
and this is how
marxist thought contributed to western
marxism and so on right uh and
you know they're definitely antecedents
to that but i think it's a very
distinctively hegelian way of teaching
the history of philosophy right right um
well i mean
pills to your question about whether or
not people teaching
the history of philosophy or even the
philosophy of history
prior to hegel in a certain maybe a
historical manner um
it's hard to say i think what i think is
important to keep in mind is that hegel
really
thematizes this for his entire system
and so when we're looking at what he
says about say the formation of any
political state
or why he's trying to justify the
creation of the state
that question cannot be divorced from or
isolated from what he says about the
role of
history in in uh political life and in
social life
and i think also i should say also
individual life right like
i this is one of the odd things about
the phenomenology of spirit which is
kind of his most famous book
uh alongside the possibility of
published lectures right because the
phenomenology isn't told as a kind of
conventional philosophy book it's almost
like a coming-of-age story
where spirit kind of progresses through
these different phases uh
in lived living time if you want to call
it that and gradually
ascends to absolute knowledge right so
everything kind of has this kind of
historical
quality to it i'm gonna de-jargonize you
a second matt
so yeah the the idea of spirit
moving through time um he sort of tells
the story of history as it's growing up
so you have
a sort of juvenile philosophy with the
greeks and then it moves
through to the medievals and moves to
the renaissance to
humanism and then it's it's growing up
in his time
which would be its movement through time
maybe we should mention too though
there we're talking about the
phenomenology of spirit
or geist mind but
today we're probably going to be more
discussing hegel's
ethics philosophy of right and
what he says more about the state then
less about his abstract philosophy yes
yes so so hegel's most famous book as
i'm sure many of listeners have probably
heard about or
or or what have you is the phronology of
spirit
uh which he wrote in eight was published
in 1807
um and the encyclopedia system as it's
called which is
which are which is made up of three
parts
uh maybe about a decade later around
1817 or so
and of course uh his philosophy of right
was published in the 19 or 1820s
uh and that you know he would lecture on
these on these topics
um but a phenomenology is his is his
most
widely read work but we're not going to
be focusing too much on that from what i
understand we're
we're you know the question is what does
he will have to say about the state
now you mentioned napoleon earlier and i
want to maybe get back to that
because of course your listeners might
be asking well wait a minute why why
would hegel support someone like
napoleon
because isn't napoleon a reactionary
wasn't he a tyrant or a dictator what's
the
what's the impetus for hegel to support
someone like a napoleon
and again this question i think relates
back to what we're just talking about
about the historical
aspect of all of this so
hegel did support the french revolution
he had some criticisms of it but
but till the end of his death he would
toast on the 14th of july he would kind
of toast the storming of the bastille
he thought the french revolution ushered
during ushered in a modern era
and he thought all of humanity could
learn from the french revolution he had
a lot of praise for it
he was critical of the jacobins
because he thought they weren't able to
properly usher in
long-lasting social and political
institutions
now when the french revolution failed
and when napoleon eventually was crowned
emperor
and started fighting the other european
nations
hegel thought this was a good thing
because he could see
that some of the some of napoleon's
policies
were progressive relative to the other
european nation states at the time
so in hegel's mind he thought yes let
napoleon come and take over prussia
because at the time german you know
germany wasn't necessarily
a cohesive state he had a mix of
different
uh smaller states that made up prussia
and hegel thought that that if napoleon
were to conquer prussia he would be able
to
modernize prussia a little bit you know
prussia would be able to be
modernized through napoleon's uh
policies as it were
so he had a progressive view of napoleon
and he was kind of
disgruntled when napoleon lost and was
defeated so he wasn't too happy about
that
that's one reason or that's one of the
main reasons he supported napoleon
and has to do with the history of the of
france and the history of europe at the
time
so he would have he always had his eye
on the historical aspect of things
so the history is important i would say
yeah i wish i mentioned
i wish i brought some info about this up
but yeah go look at the napoleonic
code listeners we're always taught in
history class that it's actually
quite a progressive code it's happening
in the context too of debates
about should we return to a monarchy
right so there are people
who want to basically make the state
dictated by the whims of a monarch and
have that justification
based on divine right they were chosen
by god
and for someone who's open-minded
not so much that his brain will fall out
like hegel i mean
he would obviously be opposed to this
maybe sort of reactionary monarchical
discourse that was going on at the time
as well i'm sure
i also think it's important to look at
the breakdown of aristocratic power
that napoleon represented right uh i
mean there are a lot of bad things that
we can say about meritocracy
and if somebody likes john rawls who
we'll talk about later on i think mayor
talkers is a bad thing
but it used to be that a lot of
positions of power in european society
were reserved for members of the
nobility uh and you know
members of the clergy you know you think
about the two estates in france right
uh and napoleon for a lot of people
especially young people like hagel at
the time
uh you know the fact that you could be
this little corsican uh who came from a
backwater
uh family and you could rise all the way
to the top and carry a lot of people
with you
would have been seen as extremely
liberating particularly
when you go and you break down a lot of
these old rigid aristocracies in
different countries
and you allow a lot of other talented
people uh
shot at the top right would that be like
the
the civil service entering into civil or
state service
yeah that's what i would like to pick up
on because what did hegel i mean
sorry what did napoleon do that was good
in the eyes of hegel was not that he
went around conquering states
it's more that when he took over a place
he universalized
codes customs rules taxation law
um i think driving on the left side of
the road having a last name
these are all universal wait
no right side of the road right side of
the road
um these are all universal codes where
he made everybody a subject
to the state as an individual but then
there's this word universalizing which
is sort of having a law that covers all
people
equally yeah and i mean
hegel sometimes criticized uh including
by a lot of marxists right for
revering uh you know the bureaucracy or
kind of
idealizing it yet but when we look at it
in historical context which i think we
always have to do
uh when we're trying to think about hey
gold right uh the fact that you could
have a
bureaucracy that's open to talent uh
where educated people can kind of
rise within it to positions of
extraordinary power at least for the
19th century this was all pretty radical
stuff
right uh used to be that you know if you
were in charge it was because you were
born into the right family
not because you happen to come from a
middle class family got a good education
and then impress the right people right
uh and there are of course limitations
to this viewpoint that we're aware of
today but
it's important to recognize that it
would have been a pretty progressive
thing
i think at least in some respects for
the early 19th century
well even just putting yourself in that
mindset of
if you're if you're in like maine's or
something and then you go to trail then
there's a whole different set of rules
that you have to learn just from
crossing like a single border
of all these different duchy states you
don't know who's in charge
you don't know what kind of temperament
that lord has
then this one guy comes in and makes
everything the same all across the board
i mean that would seem
pretty clean it would seem like this is
organized this is better so
even though we could criticize the state
it seems that would be kind of a
refreshing to have this
borderless giant nation state that's
unified by language code law
and not just by the temperament of
whoever was born into power there
sound like a good liberal elite there
hey
i'm being charitable i'm being
charitable i'm learning from borna well
i think i mean this would actually be a
good point when we could talk about
uh the state in a more modern context
because
uh a lot of the reason why the critics
of hegel that you brought up at the
beginning
were as voice versus there were is
because they saw him as eventually
offering apologias uh for the emergence
of something like bureaucracy
right you know the eu which created
these big uniform blocks
established the same rules everywhere
broke down national particularity
and establish you know this bureaucracy
rife with regulations and so on and so
forth
uh and you know these are all things
that you can maybe criticize hagel for
retrospectively but i think
we need to appreciate that at the time
it would have seemed refreshing like you
say to have some unanimity
on these things and you know reforms
regulation that weren't tied to the
whims
of an aristocrat or the king or
something right again it's the
importance of
hegel's historical understanding
right that that it changes right today
we
take these big sort of euro eurocentric
blocks
as uh a bad thing but maybe necessarily
back then
they weren't they were a new idea really
born try to move are trying to move from
this conception of the state as an
actual historical thing that hegel is
watching develop
and then his notion of the state and the
criticism against his notion of the
state
how do you see that movement from
totality
um he thought it was a liberating event
to the creation of the state in a lot of
ways how do you see that
working out contrary to the
people we brought up at the beginning
and maybe brought up uh in our previous
episode
right well um the first thing is to say
is we have to maybe think about
what hagel actually said about the state
you know why is it that he thought the
state was in some sense
necessary right so in the philosophy of
right which is his
work of political philosophy he he the
project in this book for him
is to lay out as he says a rational
conception
of uh social social life and so by
rational conception he means
this is how a kind of social order
will look like and it
if it's based on reason if it's based on
rational thought now he has reasons
and he explains what he means by
rational thought and rational thinking
has to do with his metaphysics
it has to do with what he calls the
concept and so on but for our purposes i
think we don't have to really go into
the details of that we can just kind of
deal with
what he says about the social order in
his in his in his closet right
so the first thing that i think we
should maybe get clear on is that hegel
argues that
a social order has to be able to express
the freedom of every human being right
so hegel starts off the book by arguing
for the fact that human beings have free
will
we have the capacity to exert ourselves
to
as he says uh self-determine our actions
and for hegel what it means to be free
is to be self-determining we have to be
autonomous individuals
and so no other person or
thing meaning no other kind of social
institution
or way of organizing our social order
can infringe
on on any individual human being's
freedom
so right off the bat that's paramount
for hebel if you're going to have a
sense of an economy or if you're going
to have social institutions property
rights
familial rights marriage rights law
crime and so on and so forth all of
these have to
respect and not violate human freedom
now that's what he does in the first two
big chunks of this book because he
argues for
what he calls the freedom of the will
and he relates that to his concept of
right
which is wrecked in german which just
essentially means
the law or or kind of the rightful law
the dutiful rightful law
of things so for hegel this is paramount
now what he says about the state
is he says look if we're going to have a
society if we're going to have a social
order
that is going to respect individual
human beings and their freedoms you
can't just have a social order where
there is no state where human beings are
running around
you know uh uh violating each other's
rights
like stealing things from each other or
killing each other or
so on and so forth you need to enforce
and coerce
and respect people's autonomy in some
way and so he argues for social and
social institutions he argues for
certain
cause of mistakes certain forms of
institutions that kind of are built on
this idea of free will
and in the end in the section on ethical
life this is the section he calls the
last part of his book
which deals with the kind of communal
interrelations of individuals in
in the social order there he says you
have to have a state
and his reasoning is that if individuals
if he
if human beings have to be able to
assert their freedom they need to be
reassured in a way that their freedom is
recognized
as valid by the political order
and the way to do this he thinks is to
have
a ruling body a centralized ruling state
that in a sense reflects back to the
people
their free will and so he says this
state
is the universal will of all the
individual free wills in a certain
respect
now that sounds a bit abstract but he
think about it this way all he really
means by this
is we can use modern examples because
what he's arguing for is
is effectively something like civic
rights civil rights
so if you look at the history of civil
rights movements uh
in the modern era that you can read that
or interpret that along hegelian lines
because what you know what did martin
luther king
and the civil rights movement fight for
in the 60s
well they fought for voting rights they
fought for being able they essentially
fought for being recognized by the
american state as equal citizens
right and if you can't vote
you can't assert your freedom
politically speaking
you are not counted as a free individual
and so and and there has been by the way
a lot of hegelian
interpretations of martin luther king
and the civil rights movement that kind
of argue
that you can use hegel's philosophy to
kind of write a
to kind of support these movements so
similar with
uh queer rights similar with trans
rights any kind of marginalized group
if they're seeking validation and
recognition from the state
can do so along hegelian lines in this
respect or rather
hegel's philosophy speaks to their
struggle because he thought
he thought that the state again the
state's main function of hegel is to
recognize and reflect back unto its
people
the fact that they're free in some ways
i just want to push back again
oh sorry i was gonna just add a quick uh
rejoinder to that that might um
if you're so that might rule out
anarchists anarchism
uh if you're a libertarian your ears
might have perked up with the
uh guaranteeing the freedom of the
individual
but then once you started talking about
the state you might have lost the
libertarians there because
i guess for libertarians the state
should really just guarantee
their freedom and otherwise it's freedom
from the state
but that's not exactly hegel's opinion
is it
no no i know we're gonna have to i mean
that was
a great layout to begin our dialectic um
and i know everyone's gonna want to push
back on one part of that or another but
you know on its face that sounds pretty
good right that sounds
not not out of line with uh the uh i
don't know a lokian or even a
rawlsian organization of society that
the state is supposed to recognize
people
um so eric you gave your rejoinder matt
do you want to uh
add yours yeah and i should say i agree
with everything that bournemouth says
right so this isn't rejoinder
a boerner's interpretation uh since i
share it right
i think that the kind of left hegelian
state that he's talking about
which is about the recognition of
everyone's equal rights
and the establishment of a kind of
freedom
that allows everyone's will to be
expressed politically
as equals is something an idea we're
striving for
what i just wanted to ask is isn't it
possible to give a much more
conservative interpretation
of what you're talking about and i say
that kind of fallaciously since i know
it is
right uh there are a lot of right
hegelians out there people like roger
scrutin come to mind
who would say what hegel is actually
talking about
isn't the freedom of everyone as equals
it's not their freedom through the law
that's important it's their
subordination
to the law that gives them freedom oh
jesus
and the kind of argument scrutiny would
make is that listen like
we have too individualistic a society
right now where there's too much
equality
too much freedom granted to people uh
this corrodes the kind of institutional
and civic binds that
are necessary in order to hold the state
together and so what we need is a far
greater
insistence and hegelian sense upon our
responsibility to the other
even if that means subordinating our
will at any given moment
and okay come back come back down to
earth well i'll give an example right
one of the things he talks about is
lgbtq rights
right uh and he says that there's a lot
of talk now about all this kind of
liberal permissiveness and how it is
that lgbtq people need to be treated as
equals through the law
and that it's wrong to marginalize them
on that basis
but coming from a kind of right hegelian
standpoint he says what we don't
recognize is that
just as important as freedom through the
law as subordination to the law which
enables freedom
and if the community has decided that
they don't want lgbtq people
to be allowed to do whatever it is that
they want then the free community and
the moral majority if you want to call
it
should be free to do so because that's
necessary in order to maintain a certain
level of social stability
uh and a commitment to traditions that
we think are important
i think even as a non-hegelian scholar i
could tell you that the idea of
subordination to law
would just not be defensible it's a riff
on hegel but it's not an interpretation
of hegel
that would be defensible by as what we
in the humanities call
evidence from the text well i think that
there's more to it than you might
that some people give a credit for like
i tend to agree with the standard
lefty galilean interpretation of hegel
precisely because as borna says right
you know he saluted the french
revolution until his dying day
he speaks a lot about freedom uh you
know but there is also stuff in the
philosophy of wright for instance about
maintaining a monarch uh how it is that
he doesn't think that cosmopolitan
institutions are achievable precisely
because people are attached to the
notion of the nation-state
in a way that they aren't attached to
the notion of universal humanity
he puts a fair amount of emphasis on the
importance of religion as a stabilizing
factor
so i do think that there are theoretical
resources people on the political right
can draw upon
from hegelis if you want to call it that
to support their own viewpoints also
and this is just kind of what i wanted
us to get into you know
which of these interpretations is more
correct and why should we buy
in to the left to gallium interpretation
of the state that borneo i think is
rightfully putting forward
okay so to simplify i'm going to kick
this to borna directly but we're talking
about
the conflict between the group and the
group's freedom
and then individuals as individuals and
their freedom
and then we also introduced two
distinctions a right hegelian
interpretation and a left hegelian
interpretation
born as obviously a left interpret left
hegelian interpreter
but borno would you say there's any
credibility to the other side of that
argument
uh there is um
the thing about the left right
distinction is that
it it started right after hagel's death
in 1831
because his interpreters couldn't decide
on which
hegel was uh the right hegel so
generally speaking
the quote-unquote right hegelian view
emphasizes the more conservative aspects
of hegel's philosophy and they're there
right i suppose we shall ask could the
real hegel please stand up or something
right
right and then the left hegelians
obviously have a more masturbatory
reading
but it's one thing to note that this
so in the 21st century now you know
people working on hegel today
don't really take this right left
reading that seriously because
the issue is that they they can both
find evident
evidence and attacks to support their
claims and the irony is that
hegel's philosophy is so contradictory
that even his interpreters
can't really agree which is why you have
these
vastly different interpretations that
said i would say that the
right hegelian view that matt has
outlined has two problems with it
first this idea of stability
or the idea that you know individuals
can uh um
individuals ought to obey the law
because that will stabilize the kind of
social
whole right one thing to note is that
hegel never believed in
political stability he believed in the
opposite
so hegel says that look throughout
history you have
political instability you know societies
change empires rise and fall and so on
and so he says this isn't a coincidence
this is all
happening by necessity and he argues
that
that if we look at history what's really
happening for hegel is that there's a
worldwide
worldwide movement there's what he calls
world spirit
uh kind of realizing itself through the
actions of human beings and through
their institutions and through their
societies
and so the the the form that this
spirit takes if you can put it this way
is contradiction so hegel was obsessed
with pointing out
contradictions in different societies so
the reason he was a bit critical of the
french revolutionaries for example
was that he thought look you know rob
spear and the jackman's made a mistake
their reign of terror their you know
their guillotining
of heads was their answer to a series of
contradictions they couldn't resolve
but he saw an issue with the way that
the reign of terror operated
and he thought that wasn't a coincidence
and so for hegel
he thinks that we can never do away with
contradictions or with social antagonism
there's always going to be instability
there's always going to be antagonisms
that come up
and so this idea that you know the law
and the state
can basically force
its its its people to to remain obedient
and that will kind of be
socially cohesive is anathema to hegel
because you can never do away with
contradiction which is why he thinks
things will always change
right societies and social formations to
always take new shapes
because of um social antagonisms so
that's the first thing
before you go to the second thing can i
just i think all of our marxists are
pricking up their ears
as soon as they hear contradictions yes
but
yeah this is the notion of the dialectic
which is one of the very few terms i'll
drop here but when you talk about
something be it dialectical or history
being dialectical
it's that these contradictions emerge
but they are productive
they they're not just it's not just a
forever war
it's a war in a specific direction and
that direction
tends towards freedom it's not like the
kind of contradiction that
like a scientist looks for in their
theories and their empirical
observations that
indicate that their theories are
incorrect if it doesn't match up it's
not that kind of contradiction right
but i wanted to ask i want to hear the
second thing you were going to say
but i just want to ask about
contradiction does hegel
outline a central contradiction
i think the sense we get of marx is that
the central contradiction
is between cl what class consciousness
and the the means or mode of production
whereas for hegel
i'm i'm not i'm not so clear if he ever
like
gives thematic form like that you could
say
to to any kind of contradiction that's
central to his
his his worldview so we have we have a
few things to deal with first is
the answer to the essential
contradiction um and then
and then born a second point about right
hegelians but uh victor is not here
right now he asked the same question
last week
and i suggested that it was freedom and
necessity and universal in particular
and i kind of want to know
first of all whether that's right
because i have no [ __ ] clue
but if borna has a central um
contradiction in hegel besides those
well i mean it's a tough question
because hegel never really
says here is the central contradiction
of my philosophy
right what he does do is
point to contradictions all the time and
so this is how his philosophy
this is how his system operates is
through contradictions
you know the the one thing i should note
and and this is kind of funny
is that during hegel's phd thesis
defense
um he was um you can actually read an
english translation of it
he he was asked to kind of summarize his
thesis
in four different uh points four
different theses
and one of these theses this was when he
was very young this was before he wrote
the phenomenology so
so uh this was in 1803 or four i believe
one of these theses hegel says that
contradictions is the way of the true
identity is the way of the false now
to imagine the setting you know you're
at a prussian university these old
aristotelian
theologians are sitting at the at the
desk at your thesis defense
and they read this statement i mean that
is absurd because it contradicts two
things it contradicts the law of
identity
and it also contradicts the law of
non-contradiction but but hegel really
thought this he thought look
if philosophy's business is to get out
the truth capital t
then contradictions is the way to go you
know rather than avoid them and create
logical systems that avoid
contradictions
let's go through contradictions let's
reconcile contradictions
so no he doesn't point to any one
specific
central contradiction unfortunately but
things like freedom
freedom and necessity that's a big one
that's the topic of my phd thesis by the
way
uh the universal in particular is
another big one the individual and the
social or the
individual and the world is another big
one
or the individual and god you know man
and god as it were
and hegel was aware of all of these
dichotomies all of these
um contradictory binaries if you want to
think about it this way
um but he embraced them dude
that was a tight answer i'm putting that
at the beginning of the episode that was
good
fair enough that was this coherent uh
explanation of hegla's i've ever heard
well i should like to think so
do you want to move on to the second
point yes i'm trying to um
uh matt before i do that matt if you
could just reiterate the right hegelian
reading that you did because i i think i
lost myself
sure i'm sorry i didn't mean to get back
i just think that
this is really this is kind of selfishly
moving in the direction of politics that
i'm interested in
right um and i've spent a lot of time
with wright hegelians uh
almost by necessity since i work a lot
in these regions right uh but the usual
argument they give
is to kind of give a burkian
interpretation of hegel uh you know
berkey and beaning drawing influence
from edmund burke an 18th century
british philosopher founder of modern
conservatism right
and burke was also interested in history
right and the kind of argument he makes
is that
putting it really simply the world as it
exists
now has institutions that have proven
themselves over time
you know they can be changed in some
circumstances
but we should be extremely cautious
about changing them you know
precisely because they've proven
themselves and what people are proposing
to replace these institutions with
haven't proven themselves so marriage
for example yeah marriage uh or
tradition
or you know stable political
institutions you name it right
yeah i mean you know the the so this
idea of subordination to the laws
um is is i mean yes you can find
texts in hegel or or textual support for
that claim
but it's a rather strange one to just
focus on this because it's
you know it's not as if hagel says look
the individuals can only gain their
freedom by
by subordination to the law as the law
is in itself right remember
he tries to argue that the laws of the
state are
have to you know be created have to kind
of reflect
the rational concept that that starts
off with the free will of the individual
right so hegel on the one hand thinks
look we can't do away with um
or rather the state ought not to ignore
or negate the individual's free will
because then that's not really a free
society
but neither should the state just simply
be a reflection of an undifferentiated
mass of people
right so he wasn't i mean i say this
because
hegel was also critical from a leftist
point of view he was critical of
the liberals of his day right for the
most part because he
he he didn't like this idea of treating
human beings as individual liberal
atoms you know what i mean he thought
that was corrosive and ridiculous and so
he thinks there needs to be a balance of
sorts between
again a state that recognizes individual
free wills
and um if on the other side
you know the subjects to the state or
the people that that live in this
society
well they do have to obey the law but if
they're being oppressed by the law
like some queer people are being
oppressed in today's world
then that's an infringement of their
right
as free beings hegel would argue i think
so you can really i think you can really
kind of point to two main
problems with this kind of stereotypical
right hegelian reading of hegel
um you know the one the first one i
mentioned was you know the thing about
stability
and the second one is the thing about um
the the kind of relation between the
individual wills of the people
and the kind of universal will of the
state that
is supposed to embody the will of the
people of innocent respect
okay if i could just follow that up with
kind of more down-to-earth example to
give you know pills
uh kind of uh yeah you know accept pills
preference
this is some kind of rhetoric this is
some rhetoric i see on the political
right
drawing on this kind of hegelian
language it's actually quite popular
you know i see people uh in the idw make
this kind of claim all the time right
freedom means my freedom
to enact the kind of laws that are
consistent
with our community values right
in our community a majority of the
people believe
fundamentally that same-sex marriage is
wrong
and we should have the freedom to enact
that in-law to express the ethical
spirit of the community if you want to
put it really simply right
and you're saying that we should not be
allowed to do that because that's a
violation
of the freedom of the individual is
imposing a limitation on our freedom to
express our ethical viewpoints through
law and have them
enforced by the state and not only
is that you know a violation of our
freedom in this sense
but it also corrodes the same ethical
mores that are necessary to hold our
society together
and treats everyone like they are just
individual atoms who should be allowed
to do
whatever it is that they want you know
that's pretty much like the
standard you know particularly when it
comes to sexual issues so how do you
think hegel
the proper reading of hegel let's call
it that since i think we've all agreed
that's the one we want
how would the proper hegel respond to
that
well he would what we want is the right
one
after that slim shady reference now
you're uh
the latter half of the jurassic period i
think
well there's a reason that we didn't
invite any conservatives on
and probably will never because i'm not
interested in debate
there i would guess and maybe i'm wrong
but hegel might even say that as long
as as like in
at that historical moment the laws
really do reflect the
the will of all the individuals in that
community then it's not necessarily
it's not necessarily uh a contradiction
there
the only thing would be to assume that
human nature is is
static and a historical and won't change
to revise that view and become out of
step
with the state of things and the state
itself
that's an allowance that i think is one
of the reasons why i can never dismiss
hegel out of hand despite what de las
and sartre and everybody else thinks is
because he always has that
ability for things to shift inside the
system and that's
an allowance regardless of whatever his
personal views were
and some of them were not you know
politically correct
but even if his weren't he would have an
allowance for
that idea to develop into a greater
sense of freedom
one thing i think we should just quickly
clarify you know what hegel really meant
by you know the free will and and people
asserting the free will
so he didn't mean this idea that people
can just do what they want
if you see what i mean so to matt's
question this idea that
you know people can protest a certain
law because it violates their religious
beliefs and
you know this is my community and these
are my beliefs and so on and so forth
hegel hated that he actually wrote
against that very idea
when he was alive you know he thought it
would be horrible so
one of hegel's criticisms of democracy
is sort of based on this idea he says
look
democracy is problematic because
it is totally dependent on the
contingent whims and beliefs of the mod
more or less this is similarly what
plato thought about democracy
too right but higgle says look if you
have a political system that is
always entirely democratic for any
reason meaning
every single person gets the same vote
and he thought that was a problem
because there's no necessity behind that
structure behind that political order
so if you base a law or a base
as a social order based on as you would
say
the kind of arbitrary will of the people
you know so i believe x therefore y
should happen
hegel hates this idea because there's no
necessity behind it
you know today i think this about trans
people tomorrow i wake up i change my
mind because i become more enlightened
and i endorse trans rights and he goes
say and hegel would say well okay but
we can't have a social order that is
entirely dependent upon
kind of happenstance arbitrariness of
people's
ideas in their heads right or their
beliefs of their personal beliefs
so when hegel says people are free in
their free will he does not mean
his conception of free will does not
mean that human beings
should be able to do and say what they
want that's not what he's saying
in fact he hates this idea of free will
he hates the idea of free choice
because it's not really free for hegel
free will means something very specific
it means the ability to
assert itself it means that the free
will
is free only to the extent that it is
self-determining
right and by self-determining like i was
saying
at the beginning of our of our show
means the ability for that individual
to determine him or herself without any
other
external person or structure impinging
on their ability to be self-determining
right
now what does this mean well this means
that for example
so hegel thought look human beings have
the right to have
property like a house and you know
things that you need to live
he thought that the way that you make
your free will recognizable to others
is to have things including your body by
the way
right now to give a really contemporary
example
we can read the black lives matter
protests
the rebellion that's been happening
since uh
early june in hegelian lines being
because hegel would say well look
clearly this is a society that isn't
respecting the autonomy of this big
segment of its population that have been
oppressed for years and years and years
and the the the laws in place in america
for example but also in canada
and also here in the uk aren't as
equitable
aren't as reflective of the freedoms of
human beings that you think is innate in
people
so he would have an issue with the fact
that uh
black people in america are still
fighting for their
dignity and for their equality right for
their economic and social rights
and so he would i mean you could read
hegel and support that cause on hegelian
lines if you see what i mean
i hope that answers the question no that
really clarifies things thanks oh
sorry i'd like to ask in that context
about uh
working class versus like middle class
so if
if self-determination extends to this
freedom to extend your will
is this just the state stays out of
interfering with you
or the state is also responsible for you
having
something like social mobility or should
the state be responsible for your health
should the state be responsible for
making sure that you have a home
making sure that you have access to
other things that would
enable you to live your life or is that
too much
uh interference that's a good question
um
sorry go ahead matt you you wanted to no
i was just going to give like a kind of
contemporary reading uh of hegel that
i'm actually quite fond of uh i booked a
lot in my
uh book that's coming out soon on
liberalism and liberal rights but
actually honest reading of hegel
is that self-determination has three
different forms
and a proper state is one that enables
people to be
as free as possible along all three
different dimensions maybe that's a
better way to put it
as it can possible as it's capable of
doing and
the three dimensions of freedom are
negative freedom
he draws this from isaiah berlin i
should say right a negative freedom is
pretty simple right it just means
you are unconstrained from going about
your day-to-day life to the extent
possible
right and you can associate that with
all the standard liberal liberties right
freedom of expression freedom of
religion
freedom of mobility uh freedom of life
uh then he also talks about substantive
freedom uh which
are all the kind of forms of freedom
that come from having things like
personal property
being believed uh of concern about your
health uh to the extent possible
having enough capital to actually lead a
meaningful life rather than being
faced with economic precarity and so on
and so forth uh and the last dimension
of freedom that honors talks about in
this kind of hegelian vein
uh is social or civic freedom which is
the freedom
to have a substantial say about the kind
of social institutions and laws that
govern you
and this is where he feels that even
modern welfare states fall really far
short of the mark
because he says while a lot of these
states are quite generous
in terms of the substantive freedom that
they enable for their citizens
and they're uniformly amongst the most
free states if you're just looking
in terms of negative freedom very few
people actually feel like they have a
meaningful
capacity to influence uh what's going on
at the institutional level so their
social freedom is seriously inhibited
that's the way that i usually like to
interpret it in a more contemporaneous
setting well that would seem to answer
plastic pills question
i don't know uh yes i mean that that i
mean i don't have a
um i mean honest his reading is is
interesting for that reason
um it's it's it's broadly consistent
with with kind of hegel's idea
uh but i mean you can even kind of
stretch it further so again
if we want to take the historical view
right we have to remember that hegel
was writing and lecturing on on
political philosophy in the
uh near the late 1820s
and his views changed because in the
early lectures he actually
wrote about what he calls the rabble the
rabble rousing kind of the
the the very poor angry
uh unforgotten lump and proletariat as
as marx and engels say um
and in the earlier lectures he's more um
sympathetic
to the economic problems that a lot of
people face
and he is very viciously critical of the
state for not
helping pover not helping to quell
poverty
now his views not that they change but
that
radical tone isn't really present in the
philosophy of right
and one of the reasons for this and
there's letters and other
documents that attest to this is that
hegel was at the time very concerned
with the prussian state the prussian
state was censoring
or that there was a censorship law in
place at the prussian state
at the time uh and hegel's one of
hegel's
heroes and one of his colleagues fichte
lost his job at the university because
of being charged with atheism
and so hegel was very aware that if you
know he said look if i'm going to
publish a book
on political philosophy i can't have
this critical radical tone
so there's a lot of interpreters of
hegel who kind of take that view
that he had more radical views even
until the end of his life but he had to
codify them in the language of the
philosophy of right
as to not seek the wrath of the prussian
state
that's one thing to say and another
thing to say is that
hegel wasn't he didn't live long enough
to see
full-blown industrial capitalism come to
the fore
right so hegel dies in 1831
and it's really kind of in the 1840s
1850s especially
in here in england right that uh
industrial capital
you know and the productive power of
capital really comes to the fore and so
hegel isn't alive to see
the kind of contradictions inherent in
capitalism he wasn't able to kind of
appreciate that at the time really um
and
and i personally think you can kind of
extend the hegelian project by going to
marx and ingles for that
but he uh but it is true he he really
had really critical things to say about
the state's inability or lack
of ability to help the poorest people in
society
and so the question we should ask
ourselves is what happens when the state
doesn't look after the freedom and the
well-being of its citizens
right um what happens when their
autonomy is violated either economically
or with this pandemic uh in terms of our
health
right they try to achieve a welfare
state
that was sufficiently robust and care
for everyone's needs in the 1950s
but they did so in a very top-down way
without enabling
social freedom in any meaningful sense
right this was going to be a
technocratic project
where elites were going to say here are
your needs and we're going to take care
of them for you
but because like the deimos right the
democratic population
wasn't really a part of this process
of generating the welfare state it was
only going to be a matter of time before
capital kind of struck back
seized control of the state apparatus
and used it to institute this kind of
neoliberal global order
that worked in its interests and started
to roll back the welfare state
and because you know the demos wasn't
actively involved in politics
there was very little that working-class
movements could do to prevent this from
happening
if you want to take a second crack at
establishing a truly free state
that enables substantive freedom along
with negative freedom
you have to make sure that people are
involved and that includes
at a grassroots level all the way up to
the top because if you don't the state
is eventually just going to be co-opted
by power
by capital again and it's just going to
use its authority to
claw back any benefits that uh working
people were able to achieve for a
temporary period of time
yeah that sounds about right to me i
mean it makes sense you can you can kind
of read that along kind of broadly
broadly hegelian um hegelian lines in
this respect
i don't know if we want to get back into
a question i i kind of have but it seems
like
we've sort of arrived at a contradictory
position for the state or a
contradictory role of the state
because okay on the one hand if we just
say that we're supposed to subordinate
ourselves to the law
of the state then we're we might as well
just read hobbs and forget about hegel
but for for hegel the state has to
reflect the freedom of the individual
and in a sense protect it or guarantee
it
but what about laws like like what is a
law for hegel
the state also has to regulate it also
has to
restrict freedom or make laws like
how does he sort of how do how does he
sort of articulate this
sort of dual role the state has of
reflecting freedom but also being
a sort of regulative or law making
legislative body but the law should come
not from even a democratic position but
the law should come from
this universal rationality
and i'm trying to figure out how that
could ever work in practice or how he
expects it to work in practice does he
just hope that
there are philosophers in the government
so whenever he says universal
rationality what he means
is this idea
that because look for hegel the the his
old
social political philosophy is based
around this idea
that the social order is rational right
that is necessarily
necessarily rational and what he means
by that is that
it abides by the logic of what he calls
the absolute idea
now all that means for i'm not going
through the metaphysics of it
but for our purposes the absolute idea
is a self-determining
idea it is in effect an idea of freedom
but not just an idea of freedom that is
one-sided as simply being
self-determining
it's this idea that freedom can only be
actualized or realized in the world
if it embraces its
external relation to otherness for
example
if i want to make sure that my freedom
is respected and upheld in the law i
have to work with other people
to make sure that their freedoms are
respected as well it's a universalizing
process
right so any law uh for hegel or any
sort of laws that that that come about
through his notion of the state
they have to be able to have a sort of
rational necessity behind them they have
to be universally rationally
rationally necessary and what that means
for hegel broadly is that again
it has to reflect the the
self-determining aspects
of human beings so um so for example
this idea
that that only a segment of the populace
it
can own property or rather only a second
of the populist
should have voting rights because they
can own property which was the case in
europe for the longest time until the
french revolution
which then universalized voting rights a
little bit
um that would that would go against
the self-determination of human beings
in a certain respect
and so the law while maybe partially
democratic isn't as democratic or isn't
as
universal as it maybe ought to be right
and it's not truly universal in that
respect if democracy
is not to be trusted because it's
impulsive
then is there right to revolt the only
recourse that they have it seems to me
that he
constantly comes back to this point
right that
you can only become meaningfully free
through recognizing the freedom of
another and forming a genuine relation
with them
and in the same way the state can only
be a meaningfully free place
where everyone has the same kind of
freedom uh equally guaranteed to all of
them otherwise even those who are the
beneficiaries of some kind of
inegalitarian system
will eventually be forced to recognize
that
the contradiction that this represents
is going to lead to social collapse
does that sound right yes i think i
think that's probably
probably right um but to pills this
question you know
hold on can you can you reiterate your
question i had it and then i quickly
forgot
because you asked um well let's just
let's get way out of space and turn
hegel on his head and put his head on
the ground
um if if a class of people's
right is the revolution are violated if
they're violated in minneapolis
do they have a right to revolt in
something like
like john locke said if you the
sovereign's allowed to have power over
you until it violates your power
so when hegel's talking about the
formation of these laws as an expression
of universal reason and at the same time
saying
democracy no it's too impulsive then
what is the rights of the oppressed
in that case well yes i mean this gets a
bit complicated because
remember his his criticism of democracy
is
is has to do with
forming a political society or rather
forming a
forming a society based on the idea that
you simply give into the whims
of the mob at any given time right and
so he hates that idea because it's too
contingent it's too
it's to again there's no necessity
behind it there's no
reason for people to do x y and z
because
the mob will change its view all the
time right but that's different
from the question of uh of human
autonomy
and human freedom right
because remember for hegel freedom
is paramount i mean hegel virtually
supported every revolution that he had
read about
throughout history everything from the
slave rebellions and revolts in the
roman empire
to the german peasant war to the to luth
luther's reformation so of course the
american
revolution the english uh uh revolution
the french revolution the haitian
revolution and so on and so forth
and so when you see what he says about
these things for example let's take the
haitian revolut
the french revolution because it's the
most famous example that the hegel wrote
about a lot
he supports it on the one hand because
he thinks that the
the the social conditions
in french society at the time have
created the reasons for a revolution
right so so it's almost more rational to
revolt
when the state becomes repressive than
it would be for the state to continue
repressing yes but i mean that's those
are very kind of extreme
circumstances so it's not as if and so
you know there's a reason why people
aren't revolting all the time you know
rebelling all the time but rebellions do
happen riots happen
and hegel had a very contextual view of
these things you know he's not
he's not going around moralizing about
them in an abstract way
he's trying to look at the historical
context you know
france had contradictions that that that
king louis was not resolving let's just
put it that way
and you can do the actual historical
work on this there's many great books
that
show that france was in huge debt that
there was
vast you know material inequality in
france at the time
and uh you know when when mary
antoinette says eat cake well
you know that's not gonna help anything
um and similarly
you know if we just think about the uh
the riots you know and the uprising
against police rebellion in america
in the last two months or so we can see
that the same kind of
idea or you know the same kind of
hegelian reasons are there right
so if the police force is routinely
murdering
its unarmed citizens for no real reason
then those people have a right to revolt
by necessity
they they kind of rise up and fight back
and hegel would kind of point to the
necessity of it he would kind of lean
heavily on that
but again i want to stress this is
different from his criticisms of
democracy
as simply being based on personal
beliefs and values
right freedom for him is not a personal
belief it's not a personal value
again freedom for hegel doesn't mean i
can do what i want or i should have
freedom of choice it means a very you
know it's very specific cohesive thing
the ironclad logical rational necessity
behind
human freedom that will exert itself and
explode in social
settings if it's oppressed or violated
for too long
yeah i have a bit of a harder example
for you then and matt you can jump in
right after this
a harder example i'm walking around i
want to go get a bite to eat
then the people there refuse to let me
eat
because they say you have to wear a mask
and i don't want to wear a mask
because it's going to block god's
natural breathing apparatus
that he's given me to breathe with does
the state have a right to tell me that i
must wear
a coverage to my god-given breathing
apparatus on my face and do i have a
right to revolt
in that context um well i think
hegel would say that the state has a
right to
uh you know demand that you wear a mask
because it's for your well-being and
it's for the well-being of others
right and so this covet mask thing only
works as ever
if everyone wears a mask there's a
reason that japan
only had under a thousand deaths and
they had no lockdown and it's because
everyone wore
masks right um and so hegel would say
well
you know if you think the state is
infringing on your right
because they're demanding you wear masks
to protect your life
in the lives of others then you're being
a bit of an idiot you're not really
thinking rationally
about the about your freedom and about
the freedom and well-being of others
really um and in that scenario it
wouldn't be an infringement of your
personal right remember
freedom is not simply i can do what i
want right it means
you you you are a self-determining being
and that self-determination that
autonomy is
applied to the social order and it's
applied to the laws in the state
and the social institutions so in the
social institutions and the state
for the good of the people say look
wearing masks
which is just like wearing a seat belt
which you should also do
right if this can save lives then please
do it because we're trying to save lives
at the moment
and hagel were alive today i'm sure he
would look you know he would he
would he would scoff and be insulting to
the people who don't wear masks
and he could be very very mean sometimes
so
this is a little bit of a slippery slope
though right because then
when or what is the measure and i think
it's
going to be some word like the absolute
or something like that but what is the
measure
of when it is in the interest of the
group
and when is it not in the interest of a
group anymore
who like where does the measure come in
for that resolution of the contradiction
between the individual and the social
group
it's a complicated issue because hegel
thought that
that you know on the one hand the
individual like you know the autonomy of
the individual has to be respected
right but i want to again i want to
clarify when hegel says freedom is
freedom means self-determination again
this doesn't mean that you can do what
you want or you can
you know you're free to choose to have
coke or pepsi
you know what i mean um you know
self-determination doesn't mean i can
i can do what i want and society should
just allow me to be free and it should
just let me do what i want
um can you see that but if i wasn't free
to choose coke over pepsi i would feel
pretty [ __ ] constrained okay because
yeah one of them is a nice
decent beverage uh and the other is
basically just
swell okay so let's just say that that's
true
i'm i'm a coke person myself so
i agree with you but um but you know i
mean the point
is that that you know so hegel
criticizes
this kind of freedom of choice idea of
freedom and he calls it arbitrary
right he says look if if if you think
freedom
means you know i should be able to act
based on my emotions or based on what i
uh see outside of you know coke or pepsi
you know i should have a choice
then hagel says look you're not free for
two reasons because for hegel freedom
means self-determination
and that means your you know you use
your free will
to externalize or to express your
self-determining capacity
and so the question is well wait a
minute what does self-determination
mean or um what's the content of
self-determination
uh and hegel says well look there is you
know there's no distinction between the
content and the form of
self-determination it's just
self-determination
that's what it means by freedom
so he criticizes this idea that you know
i'm free if i can
act according to how i feel and think
because
uh you're not really free because that
you know there's no necessity behind
that because it's entirely dependent
upon how you're feeling
so for example if i want to go and buy a
can of pepsi
right that wouldn't be a free act for
hegel because the content of that action
namely me going and buying a can of
pepsi
doesn't just arise out of my
being as a self-determining being it
arises from my
personal want for pepsi and
if you interrogate that that need that
thirst for pepsi you realize that i was
you know i received uh propaganda from
commercials to make me think that i want
pepsi
and it's not really my choice at all
it's the choice of the
pepsi company for example so if you're
in that position and you're
compelled to make a choice that choice
isn't free
because the content of your choice is
something that is imposed on you from
without it's something that opposes on
you from someone else
if you see what i mean so what
constitutes political action
ever then because our only political
action is to vote
and from what you're saying that kind of
vote is not a real
actual free decision in the first place
so what could be a political decision
uh well i mean it could be right so for
example if the so if the political
decision to vote is based on the idea of
extending the freedoms of other human
beings
then that is a that is properly aligned
let's say with the necessity of freedom
for hegel in this respect
but if you're you know but if we're
voting to
um well if we're voting to suppress the
freedoms of a certain group
then of course that's not necessarily
aligned with this idea of freedom now is
it
no it's it's more about what a what it's
more about what constitutes
a political action because by what
you're saying liberal versus
conservative democrat versus republican
or
labor versus conservative tory these
none of these are real choices i'd
actually like to weigh in on that by
saying that i think again the richness
of this
is in demonstrating that a lot of things
can have political significance
even if they don't appear to be
political on the surface of it
uh so imagine you have an abusive
husband and
what he really wants is love and
recognition from his wife
but he lives in a patriarchal society
he's in a society
and a situation where the laws give him
all the power to dictate the terms of
this relationship
he might think at some point well the
best way to get love uh
is to force my wife to demonstrate she
cares for me
by doing everything that i say and she
can have no choice in the matter
right and then any time when she tries
to rebel against my expectations
i'm going to use physical violence or
the threat of law and coercion
in order to get her back on track right
and bovar would say that in this kind of
circumstance since because what this
person really wants
is love and recognition from another by
constraining her
free choice he's not going to be able to
determine himself in the way that he
wants and of course she's not going to
be able to do so either since she's
imposed in these kinds of
by these kinds of constraints so a very
political action in these circumstances
might be for this both of these
individuals to say our relationship is
toxic
uh and it's predicated on all these bad
social circumstances that tell us what
men and women should do
so we need to break out of that and try
to have a more emancipatory relationship
where both partners are going to stay
with one another because they truly care
about one another
and this is what they want to do in
order to
achieve self-determination together and
from the kind of locus of what seems
like a very personal choice
you can expand and derive far more
obviously political consequences right
that patriarchy is bad and we need to
get rid of it
because it's the only way men and women
are ultimately what about what about
getting rid of it
how do you do that i'm talking about
apropos the state what is a political
action
besides revolt this is what i was trying
to get at right
now for someone like de beauvoir
following hegel right the decision to
create a more free relationship
with this other person might not seem
political on the surface of it
but it actually has political
significance but you could say that
about anything
that well but i think that's kind of
again where the richness of his analysis
comes in right where he says that
i see that as a paucity of analysis if
if that's the only recourse you have is
to be nicer to people
i don't think you're saying being nice
to people i think he's saying that
you're not going to get what you want in
this relationship if you're trying to
force someone to be with you
and it's when enough people gradually
start to feel this way
that about you know certain forms of
constraints that exist in their life
that you start to see a contradiction
emerge between how what it is that
people
want and how it is that institutions and
the state
uh try to impose constraints on people
and that's when you start to see
revolutions occurring i think a little
bit of the problem
of the way we talk about hegel in these
situations is that
is that hegel again is this historical
contextualist
thinker right so when you look at at
something that's happening today
and then you go back to hegel's
philosophy and you ask
what constitutes political action what
constitutes
this or that what we're really asking
for these eternal
rules that at any time and place we can
determine
what constitutes political action or
what constitutes equality between the
state and the individual
but what hegel's main point is that no
philosophy can transcend its own time
philosophy's job in a sense is to
comprehend
its own time and when we look for these
universal rules that apply to all times
in all places we're sort of
going against this this historicizing
ethos
of hegel's philosophy as well right like
even friedrich jameson said
says always historicize that's the point
so when we sort of
do this back and forth motion of well
this is happening now
i'm going to go look at this philosophy
and then i'm going to derive from it a
rule that i can now apply to this time
and place
it it sort of runs against the grain of
it's a problematic way of talking about
hegel's philosophy we're trying to cash
it out
in the pragmatist sense and that's not
and that
that i don't know that's maybe that's
not a great way to deal with hegel's
thinking
well i think it's a great way right
because one of the things that he points
out is again
the owl minerva only sets at dusk right
and sometimes actions that seem highly
personal and apolitical
in hindsight take on greater historical
significance
say opening a gay bar right if i were to
open a gay bar now
probably wouldn't have all that much
significance in canada or even the
united kingdom right if i decided to
open a gay bar
in 1950 that might seem like a fairly
trivial personal decision where people
can come in and drink and
smooch and do all that kind of stuff but
has more historical significance seen in
hindsight
uh since it was an effort to kind of
change people's
conception of themselves their relations
with one another
and the kind of self-determining freedom
that was appropriate
right and with seven years uh looking
back we can say well when that club
opened up
and you know gays were allowed to go in
and live their lives and not be
interfered with
this was kind of a landmark moment even
if the people who opened it up
weren't attending it to be this kind of
big significant
thing they just wanted to have drinks
and hook up you know what i mean
i think that bobar says something
similar right uh when women start to
stand up for their rights and say don't
tread on me you know if i want to be
with you it's because i should be
i should want to be with you not because
the law forces me to that might seem
extremely personal but the first person
who decides to break up with her husband
and live an independent life
even if she's doing it just for herself
in hindsight that takes on greater
political significance
but that's a good way to look at it
right like the reason
hegel's opposed for instance to the
discourse of natural rights
is because natural rights are pre-given
they give
any historical state of things or any
moment at which
humans think about themselves and
determine their own human nature
and again if freedom is the concept of
self-determination
then the whole discourse of human rights
and what it's predicated on
goes against the very spirit of hegel's
philosophy so you can look back and say
well that has historical significance
for me today based on the way i conceive
of human nature here and now
but you can't say i'm going to go to
hegel's philosophy and look for a rule
or a yardstick
by which to measure political action
today or by which to measure the
significance of events that are
happening today
that's the distinction i wanted to make
one way is a bad
reading of hegel and the other way is is
more in line with it i think
borno what are you think well i i mean i
i
i largely agree with with with uh both
matt and
and eric i think they both point to
things that are true about hagel's
philosophy
because he he he um
i mean paradoxically and and you know on
the one hand you know his political
theory he does say look you know this
this conception of the state that i'm
giving you is rational
um you know the rational state you know
looks like this and so a lot of
interpreters have read this as being a
normative claim as being
a claim of how a political society ought
to look like or should
look like right on the other hand
and this was more kind of common during
the cold war but on the other hand
hegel's um the conception of the state
that he does present
in the flossie of right in some ways
[Music]
reflect the prussian state of the
1820s not entirely and there's really
good important work
to show why that is not the case but
it it isn't so it reflects the russian
state and it does it in some respects
right and so for anyone who's trying to
make sense of what the hell is going on
with hagel's political theory
it's a bit of a paradox or it's a bit of
a contradiction itself
because on the one hand he says like
matt just pointed out
he says that you know philosophy always
comes
late on the scene of things you know
philosophy philosophy interprets
history and society when that era when
that moment in
human history is on the decline so
philosophy for hegel can only make sense
of a political social order when that
political social order
is uh has kind of had its day in the sun
and is disintegrating on the other hand
he also says philosophy and this is
something eric pointed out
philosophy is nothing but the present
temporal moment
comprehended in thought so on the one
hand hegel is saying philosophy always
comes too late
and the other hand hegel is saying
philosophy tries to articulate
its present moment in history all the
time
now if you combine these two things what
he's really saying
and this is my reading this is what i'm
trying to do my phd thesis
i think what he's really getting at here
is that
politically philosophy's job is to just
kind of look at its
present moment in history try to vaguely
destruct
describe it point out the contradictions
point that the problems
and in doing that in comprehending its
present thoroughly
you sharpen those contradictions which
then create the conditions for a new
form of society that according to hegel
is a freer and better and more just and
good society
so i think you can read him as
as so if again remember we initially
talked about the historical view
that that we have to keep in mind when
thinking about hegel right
and this applies to his own philosophy i
think
and so the question you know what should
what constitutes a political act
is for hegel a a historically situated
question
but people have tried to give hegelian
readings
of certain historical
moments in in in modern history right so
so in hegel's philosophy of history what
he says
is he says look human beings we act from
our passions right
we act from emotion from what we think
so human beings he says
we walk around our day-to-day lives just
living our lives
but he says sometimes our individual
acts and this is what matt was
explaining in his example sometimes your
personal
acts can have what hegel calls
world historical significance you know
rosa parks
sitting on the bus initiated
in a sense the the civil rights movement
of the 60s
and so individual personal acts can
sometimes
align with a bigger historical moment
but there's really no way we can really
anticipate it we can kind of try to
anticipate in some ways
but it's impossible to know
philosophically at least
ahead of time you can only comprehend
this after the fact
you can only think about the necessity
of your actions
and what the effects they've had
from the standpoint of it having
happened in the past if you see what i
mean
and i want to say that like hegel also
has wonderful egalitarianism about him
and world historical significance that
you don't see in other figures like
niche
or carlisle right because you know to
take some of the examples that we
brought up right
you know the person who started the arab
spring uh just
was tired of being pushed around by a
bunch of police officers who wanted
bribes and
let him sell his fruit and he kicked off
a revolution right
and that's not what you see in some of
these i think bad interpreters of hegel
who say that the only people who matter
are people like napoleon right riding on
his horse and he's the one changing the
world
or stalin as a later interpreter will
say
yeah because it seems to me you can
apply this to things that seem much more
mundane on the on the surface of it uh
because it's just people trying to live
their lives but actually retrospectively
it has real significance
what they're doing right all right i'm
very sorry and it feels like we could go
on but that sounds like a good note to
wrap it up
on as we are reaching our agreed upon
quit time nice that time just flew by is
that just me
yeah that's our probably our longest one
anyways i'm i'm hoping that this is now
the
definitive podcast episode on
how to read hegel well and how to read
him charitably
rather than rather than the way that
most of the people we often talk about
uh discredit him for which is a whole
bunch of things like
he's too bourgeois he's elevating
bourgeois values
ignoring the working class espousing
some technocracy or whatever but we'll
have to talk
about that in a future time um borna if
you'd like to come
back i think we'd love to have you back
you're you're sounding kind of like
allah embeds you at the end so
that could be a a soon topic to discuss
again
sure um but are there any final thoughts
before i uh
before i lock this down and we say
goodbye and roll the music
oh boy final thoughts on hegel never
i feel i feel a little bit overwhelmed i
feel like i learned more today since
since grad school i i would say i think
that's entirely appropriate since
i mean does anybody read hegel and not
come away at the end of it or discuss
ego thinking like
god damn that was a lot you know it's a
lot to [ __ ] take in
i i don't know anybody who sits there
and is just like ah you know
we talked about him and you know it's
it's pretty simple
basic stuff whatever right self-evident
truths
i gotta commend borna for not dumbing it
down but also
not using terminology or overusing
terminology i felt very unalienated
listening to you oh good
uh cover it not compromising and so
blading the [ __ ] out of mine and matt's
little back and forth there that was
good
we didn't even we didn't even talk about
sublation this week
like we can well i mean that's a whole
different you have to get into his
metaphysics at that point
i just want to say one thing about alpha
bung or whatever it is
there are 28 distinct meanings in german
for
aufhebong and it can mean something like
putting your suitcase up on a shelf
so i don't know german but i was shocked
by that because this is like everyone's
like oh sublation but no it means
canceling creating putting up taking off
putting down
destroying so i think and hegel yes and
hegel and hegel
means all of those meanings at the same
time whenever he says
or sublation or supersession as it's
sometimes
i think the philosophy so it says
everything from you know you should get
recognition to
you should put your suitcase in the
right place that's a very sensible idea
world yeah we're all hysterical
it's a very german thing to suggest too
make sure you're you're on the right
rack
yeah if you wanna if you want to study
uh if you want to study law today it's a
reschedule shaft which is uh
right wrecked it's science of right
thanks very much
borna and you other guys i'll see you
later um
yeah all right
[Music]
that means just turn off your recording
by the way i guess you left
[Music]
you